Catherine thank you a Buffalo Bills
player Demar Hamlin has confirmed he
will return to football the sport that
nearly killed him three months ago the
bills put out this video showing Hamlin
working out with his teammates yesterday
later at an emotional news conference he
revealed what caused the collapse on the
field during a game in January doctors
call it commotio Cordis a rare condition
when an impact to a person's chest at a
specific moment in their heartbeat
triggers Cardiac Arrest our national
correspondent jerika Duncan is here with
more on Hamlin's return jarika good
morning good morning to you Nate you
know Bill's management said Hamlin met
with three specialists in the off season
and all of them agreed he was ready to
play it's a remarkable turn of events
from a harrowing moment that shook the
NFL to a comeback story that is much
much bigger than football
I've been beating statistics my whole
life so I like my chances here Demar
Hamlin was full of confidence and
gratitude as he announced his much
anticipated return to the Gridiron they
almost lost me like I died on national
TV in front of the whole world
it's into the game's first quarter
Hamlin took a hard hit to the chest
stood up then collapsed seconds later
medical staff resuscitated Hamlin on the
field before he was rushed to the
hospital he didn't wake up for two days
so the diagnosis of pretty much what
happened to me was
basically commodio quartus it's a direct
blow at a specific point in your
heartbeat that causes Cardiac Arrest I
think most experts agree that a
commercial artist is not a reason to
exclude someone from playing sports Dr
Leo yankelson is a cardiologist at NYU
langone is he more susceptible to a
serious injury when it comes to his
heart because this happened generally
speaking regarding commotion quarters it
appears to be a sort of singular event
uh where that event does not predict any
further Cardiac Arrest this event was
life-changing
but it's not the end of my story it's a
story that goes beyond the game Hamlin's
name and number three jersey are now
symbols of resilience and he's bringing
awareness to the importance of CPR and
defibrillation which saved his life my
heart is still in the game I love the
game it's something I want to prove to
myself not nobody else
his heart is still in it Hamlin said
physically he's building back up from
zero to a hundred and added his love for
football stems from quote the unity that
it creates between all people of all
aspects of life I think everyone can
agree we're happy to see that yes he was
able to make that decision yes yes yes
is it the right decision do you
understand it I understand it I know
there's hesitation from fans that are
saying why go back to the game right but
who are we to tell him what to do he is
the author of his own book let him write
the rest of his story
[Music]
and he knows what he's going up against
and he loves the game and the doctor
said it would be good for his mental
health yes to go back yeah now let's
just cheer him on yeah you don't have to
be a Bills fan to be cheering a mind
that's right A lot of people in this
corner thank you very much